hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time for action
as we explore some of the greatest
fights that Hunter Hunter has to offer
now it's kind of weird because despite
the fact that hunt hunter does fall into
the battle manga category for all
intents and purposes it doesn't really
subscribe to stand a turn in combat at
least not in the latter portions of the
series but it does still manage to pull
off some superb spectacles often in
viewing them with a great deal more
depth and standard punchi punchi series
wood so it's time to honour those pieces
of action here today the criteria for
this list being fairly simple first up
we will only be exploring canon Hunter
hunter material which mostly means that
anything that happened in movies is not
up for contention secondly I guess I
should also state the might definition
of the word fight is quite broad it can
be generally summarised as an exchange
of violence between two or more parties
I just add this because I know the
internet can be a bit weird about
semantics so just so you know we're
looking quite broadly here but with that
out of the way let's begin welcome to
the top 5 best fights in Hunter hunter
number 5 Otto Kahn versus Neff Peter
alright we are starting out with one of
the most sinisterly epic moments in the
series which was the culmination of
gongs entire character arc during the
chimera and story seeing him pushed into
a situation where his desperation anger
and sorrow transcended anything most of
us will ever know and allowed him to
form a deadly vow to summon all of the
power he would ever have in order to
exact retribution upon a very very
unfortunate nephew Peter this is a fight
in terms of technicality alone I'd
actually go so far as to describe it as
a massacre and one of the most brutal
encounters that this series has ever
offered us it's really strange because
viewing it I am simultaneously elated
that Peto is being finally delivered
this sort of justice that they deserve
there is also this subconscious
knowledge that the longer the fight
lasts the more gone will lose himself
and pay an even greater price for the
power he's invoked so even though it's
so ridiculously one-sided it still keeps
you on the edge of your seat but also
being a hunter hunter battle it proves
that godlike power can be nigh on
irrelevant as betos post mortem nen
manages to claim one of groans arms
which leads to my absolute favorite
moment where Gahan uses his dismembered
arm as a weapon to smack PTO's corpse
all the way back down internally this
fight was a perf
Antiguans involvement in the arc it was
dark full of despair and I think for the
first time gave us a proper empathetic
bridge into exactly how gone had been
feeling this whole time it was a very
memorable sequence to watch the one that
was so much more than just a simple
fight showcasing how to Akashi is
supremely capable of in twining greater
concepts into action and using combat as
a mere tool to betray them rather than
using emotion to facilitate the
necessity of combat an absolutely
brilliant fight and one that should go
down in the history books both the anime
and manga mediums number four
Hisoka versus crawler so here's a unique
one because there's battle to my eternal
annoyance still has not been animated to
this day despite it being one of the
most intriguing pieces of action that
Tadashi has ever put to paper it's also
far from equal just as with our previous
contender as from start to finish
crawler completely outclasses his
opponent by displaying the true
potential of bandits secret in
combination with his keen intellect and
there are so many abilities and crazy
combinations of play in crawler versus
Hisoka that it made my mind melt when I
first read it because not counting
bandits secret Rolo has six new
abilities to play with and he very
rapidly switches between the
combinations as the readers are left
blank Lee staring at Hisoka and relying
on him for an explanation of what's
actually happening but the strategy
itself was pure genius and it's
incredible to watch he so could be
trumped at every step of the way during
this battle by an opponent who did
nothing but outthink him
it really created a stark contrast
between these two combatants one a
highly strategic and heavily utility
prioritized fighter whilst the other is
this more improvised barge in 20
situation with your one-and-a-half heart
- and see where life takes us kind of
guy and this fight showed us the utter
decimation of the mindset of the latter
handing a character who for all intents
and purposes was invincible up until
this point in the story an incredible
defeat and even and death and were it
not for he soaked his own personal
lustful life and invoking post-mortem
men that would have been the end of him
but instead what this fight ends up
doing is setting up an inevitable round
to clash where I suspected things are
going to go very very differently and to
be honest the only reason why this fight
is not further up on this list is
because I haven't seen it animated once
it is and if it's done well and that is
an entirely different ballgame
number three
Ruvo gain versus Korra pika in this
fight we see what I would describe as
the ultimate showcase of raw power
versus supreme strategy with a dash of
revenge added for flavor for some
context at this point in the series
Whoville gain seems like an unstoppable
monster he was simply too powerful for
anybody to take on or so it seemed
because this is the fight that would
truly introduce us to the possibilities
of Nan combat and how there can never be
any certainties in battle Korra pika
chose working carefully as a test
subject viewing him as the ultimate
source of raw power amongst the Phantom
troupe a group of individuals that his
particular abilities were tailor-made to
deal with as a result there was no point
in this match where Korra pika was in
the slightest danger of being overtaken
but it was still an incredible fight to
watch because seeing a fuking in action
is quite the spectacle very reminiscent
of the more Dragonball style combat
where strength is everything and he
attains quite the serious presence due
to that and then watching crap occur
just walk all over him that was just wow
that propelled Karaka into the
stratosphere of respect in my mind I
mean I said before that there can never
be any certainty in non-combat
but that's only insofar as you don't
know your opponent's abilities Karaka
analyzed over gain and he was so
confident that he even brought a shovel
to the battlefield to bury over gains
eventual corpse but like many fights in
the series this wasn't a straightforward
action showcase with gratifying results
because even after Crocker kills over
gain we are left with this overwhelming
sense of well did crop occur actually
win because even though he didn't take
any standard damage this encounter
thrust him further into the darkness
than we'd ever seen him at this point
and he also failed in extracting any
information whatsoever from move again
so it was a really bitter victory in
retrospect and I like being left on that
lingering sense of well I don't really
know how to feel about what just
happened such great mixed emotions
generated from a superb narrative and
very aesthetically appealing
choreography number two gon vs. Hisoka
heavens arena so this conflict is what I
would pinpoint to be the exact moment in
time where I fell for this series in
terms of sheer choreography and
adaptation to the animated medium this
stands out above all other fights in the
series in my opinion I can watch the
opening exchange of this match
and over and over again never getting
bored and still managing to feel the
tension that is crafted so brilliantly
with heavy use of a minimal yet powerful
soundscape accompanying every hit it's a
real hold-your-breath moment when this
begins and succeeds in drawing you into
the action as if you're a participant of
this fight as well and that is something
that is so rare to achieve even in some
of the greatest anime bounce and the
first portion all culminates in a single
punch from gone at which point the
soundscape just cut in this fantastic
beat drop moment where we as the
audience know that gone has effectively
won this fight by being able to take
that first step towards Hisoka that is
of course despite the fact that he does
obviously lose the match and by quite a
wide margin as well but that really
wasn't the point of this the point was
to return the insult that Hisoka had
given him during the hunter exam I mean
the rest of the fight is also great with
calm being pushed to his limits against
he soaked his bungee Komatsu but nothing
really compares to the glory that is
that opening exchange which will be
forever etched in my mind although there
is one fight that manages to top even
that and I'm sure at this stage most of
you can probably guess what that fight
is number one Metro versus marijuana so
as we arrive at our number one fight in
the series all of a sudden realize that
every conflict we've examined here today
has been completely one-sided and yet
still somehow incredibly exciting all
across the board and this fight here is
the king of all conflict within the
entirety of hunter hunter I can never
recall feeling as much hype as I did
when net were first activated the 100
type Guan Yin Bodhisattva and gave us
our first glimpse of what the pinnacle
of power in this world looks like the
sheer speed strength and intellect that
went into this bount is or inspiring and
incredibly satisfying in terms of its
eventual outcome a lot of the fights
I've mentioned so far left me on a very
iffy note which I have praised but
natori versus marijuana somehow managed
to leave me completely satisfied from
both perspectives marijuana because he
was able to use complex strategy to take
down Network piece-by-piece and
necessary because he was able to
implement painfully simple strategy to
ensure that an end would be put tomorrow
a.m. by incorporating the poor man's
rows into the plan everything in between
is more or less an exercise in network
gratifying himself by taking everything
he'd ever wanted in life which was to
face off against the ultimate of
which resulted in a visual banquet for
all of us especially in the anime and I
really can't emphasize enough just how
rewarding it was to see a character like
natural pushed to his absolute limit in
showcasing the true potential of
humanity as well as its true terror in
the face of defeat this fight could have
a thesis written on it in regards to
every aspect it explores whether it'd be
simple stuff like how to structure a
satisfying piece of story with two
overpowered beings or something much
deeper like an exploration of what it
means to be human and in the end who
personified humanity better natural or
marijuana because there is an argument
to be made for both or whether or not
they just represent different sides of
the same coin it is absurd that an anime
fight can force me into wanting to think
on this level through what is generally
meant to be a mostly mindless
entertainment field exercise but that is
what network versus marijuana does for
me and that is why I consider it to be
by far the greatest conflict in the
series and that pretty much does it for
the top-five best fights in Hunter
hunter if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produced in general
then please do consider donating to the
New World review patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time and please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan route takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your favorite fights in Hunter hunter
this has been the New World review and
I'll see you next time
I found the channel a little while ago
and I have to say that your content is
really good especially the hunter hunter
videos question do you think Takashi
will explain the origin of nen we'll
leave it as a mystery and which way do
you prefer him to take first of all
thank you very much for the kind words
and secondly I think he kind of already
has I mean then is just the name of the
art form that is used to wield and
manipulate or essentially and it comes
from the basic idea that all living
things possess a certain quantity of
aura that effectively represents their
life force nen is just the actual
practice of harnessing that for whatever
purpose the user so desires I feel like
any more detailed explanation than that
probably isn't necessary like I would
absolutely hate it if at some stage in
the story it was explained that nen was
a substance bathed in humanity by some
godlike being or whatnot
no I really do think it's pretty good as
it is which group do you think will win
against a fight the Royal Guards or the
Phantom troop look until proven
otherwise I have to go with the Royal
Guard they're just far too powerful and
the only troop member I see being able
to stand up to even one of them is croa
and even then he isn't the type of
person who operates efficiently in an
improvised situation he's much much
better if the conflict has been planned
so if Cola understands the Royal Guard
and is given a couple of months to
prepare then maybe I could see him
taking one of them down but they're just
such intensely powerful beings with
unfathomable or reserves especially Peto
being a specialist because they can just
go ahead and create any number of new
abilities designed to deal with any
situation I mean really when you think
about it the only member of the Royal
Guard who ended up being actually
defeated was done so by gone achieving
how equal to that of Maryland so I can't
say it's looking great for the troop but
feel free to try and change my mind in
the comment section